certes il ya toujours cette idée que je
prends l'illustration de la théorie
critique de la race qui est la plus
claire là dessus la théorie critique de
dollars à s'est fondé sur deux prémisses
la première le racisme et le pire péché
qui existe et la seconde il est
intégralement dans notre système dans
nos structures dans nos normes dans nos
dans nos structures de pouvoir dans les
airs archi domination dans notre langage
dans notre manière de serrer la main
pour ceux qui vont plus loin les micros
agression raciste si vous voulez peuvent
être potentiellement partout parce qu'il
suffit qu'une minorité perçoivent
quelque chose que mettons du racisme pur
que defacto ça en devienne donc on a un
biais de confirmation qui est déjà
stratosphérique et face à ça ça se
décline de manière différente la langue
le mal est partout on va faire une autre
langue
le racisme il est partout donc c'était
assez pratique on voit qu'on assiste
émises et on n'a plus besoin de donner
des preuves si moi je vous dis telle
personne at-elle jours a commis un acte
raciste on va être obligés de vérifier
ces falsifiable lorsque vous dis que le
système est raciste jemappes ou de la
charge de la preuve n'est plus à
vérifier et l'eau qui a toujours cette
idée que les dominants et créé le
système est un côté très incertain
complotisme par moments le système a été
créé par des dominants pour leurs
privilèges et ils vont chercher à
opprimer les marginaliser serre que ça
c'est le point commun de toutes ces
théories différentes vous ne trouverez
pas une théorie qui rendent pas dans ce
cadre là donc de ce point de vue là ce
terme par ac limo qui regroupe en effet
théorie critique de la race indigène
isme et ses écritures inclusive toutes
ces choses là ont un même parapluie qui
est de dire notre système est abominable
nous ne pouvons pas comme on l'a dit à
leur faire des petits un amendement avec
ce système c'est le mal incarné il faut
le détruire il ya une fameuse phrase qui
revient souvent en anglais we want
destroy the southwest gros on va pas
défaire la maison du maître avec les
outils du maître dire qu'il faut
repenser tous les outils linguistiques
les outils sociologique afin de sortir
de notre paradigme de la blanche cité
notre paradigme occidental pour
reconstruire une fois qu'on aura tout
détruit à partir des cendres quelque
chose de radicalement nouveau ça demande
pas ça cherche à décoloniser
[Musique]